hey everyone I'm Walter Bernays yak and
this is top five here we countdown the
best and worst performances of our most
beloved actors today we take a look at
the worst of everyone's favorite blind
lawyer no not that one
there we go Ben Affleck last week we
discussed his best but now we get down
to the worst
the thing is though to be honest Ben
Affleck is actually pretty solid in most
of his movies sometimes the movie is
really bad but even when he's not great
he's at least okay
there's nothing offensively bad some of
this list may shock you but I want you
to remember Fantastic is a really good
actor who is just now hitting his prime
so now that his newest movie the
accountant hit theaters last weekend
let's count down the top five worst Ben
Affleck performances let's leave these
roles in the past number five rafe
mccawley in Pearl Harbor this movie has
gotten some flack to say the least and
while Ben is decent in a few scenes the
writing often betrays him when you look
at the whole picture of course based on
the real-life bombings in 1941 Pearl
Harbor uses the attacks as a backdrop
for a love trial between lieutenant
Evelyn Johnson and childhood best
friends first lieutenant Rafe McCawley
and first lieutenant Danny Walker Rafe
and Evelyn become an item before he
volunteers to help the Allies overseas
while their race plane goes down he's
pronounced dead together in mourning
Danny and Evelyn become close and
eventually form a romantic relationship
Rafe is later found to be alive and his
return is met with confusion among his
friends there's not much time for Danny
and rape to talk things out before Pearl
Harbor is bombed and the resulting
action by the u.s. to formally get
involved in world war two first off this
movie is freaking long and when you have
a bad movie that is really long it makes
everything worse leave it to Michael Bay
to turn one of the biggest tragedies in
American history into a CW drama that's
basically the level of acting we get
from everyone here too there are a lot
of good actors in this movie but they're
giving crap to work with it's just
letters I mix them up sometimes that's
all I mean I just get them backwards
sometime the films got a Titanic vibe to
it a big tragedy happens but we're
supposed to care more about three
characters that all three actors
struggle to make interesting or genuine
I can't blame this one all on Affleck
but there are a few scenes where he's
the focus and it's difficult to sit
through there are worse performances but
besides the actual bombing sequence
Pearl Harbor is pretty useless number 4
AJ Frost and Armageddon hey it's Michael
Bay again look I know a lot of people
love this movie I get it an Affleck once
again isn't really all that bad here but
when you're trying to make animal
crackers sexy it probably isn't going to
come off well an asteroid the size of
Texas is headed for Earth
nASA has one option to ensure the
survival of the planet drill into the
center of the asteroid and plant a
nuclear bomb so they hire the world's
most famous oil driller Harry Stamper to
take care of the problem and save the
world
Harry only agrees to the mission if he
can bring his crew with him including
the young and confident AJ who is
against his wishes dating his daughter
Grace
a lot of the writing here is once again
to blame for a flex performance but not
as much as in Pearl Harbor a flicks
usual charming and likable personality
does not work very well in Armageddon I
really don't think that the animal
cracker qualifies as a cracker
well because it's sweet which to me
suggests cookie and you know me putting
cheese on something sort of defining
characteristic but makes a cracker
cracker there's way too much cheese and
corn mixed in there to take anything
seriously also how many times is the
name Harry said in this movie then even
knew what they were making wasn't the
best as they were filming it in the DVD
commentary for the movie Ben says when
he asked Michael Bay why NASA is
training oil drillers to be astronauts
instead of the other way around they
told him to shut the fuck up that
actually explains a lot number three
then Alan in Shakespeare in Love this
movie won the Best Picture Oscar in 1999
it was up against Saving Private Ryan
which is the more memorable movie this
fictional love story between William
Shakespeare and viola de Lesseps takes
place in the 1590s and centers around
the creation of Romeo and Juliet as
Shakespeare II is under pressure to
quickly write a new play viola disguises
herself as a man so she may act onstage
viola and Shakespeare fall in love and
this helps inspire the struggling
playwright
to develop one of his great works upon
watching this the movie is unremarkable
I mean it's okay I don't really
understand why there's a big Oscar buzz
around it the time must have just been
right for something like this to get a
lot of attention I don't think it holds
up very well at all Ben doesn't have a
huge part in this but I mean come on at
this point in his career something like
this was a very strange choice can't
argue with results I guess though it was
very successful are you going to do it
like that what a weird casting decision
his pre-established personality clashes
too much with how this character was
supposed to be and he just didn't do
enough to change that perception at that
point in his career this was a misfire
but his top two performances are much
worse than this number two Larry G Lee
injili this movie has a horrible
reputation I remember hearing awful
things about it when I came out in 2003
and even a few years after is it as bad
as people said it was not quite but yeah
it's still really bad low ranking
mobster Larry G Lee is ordered by his
boss to kidnap the mentally challenged
brother of a federal prosecutor due to
his boss not trusting him G Lee is
joined on the job by Ricky a female
gangster who goes by the beat of her own
drum when things start to get more
dangerous G Lee and Ricky have to decide
how to handle the situation as romantic
feelings develop the guy Affleck plays
here giggly pronounced Gigli around -
really right
he's a very off beat carrier and not in
a good way I don't really understand
what's happening for most of this movie
and his random bizarreness doesn't help
I am the rule of fucking cool I'm the
bull you're the cow all right bull cow
I stopped it suck my dick calm it's not
funny
so what purpose does all that stuff
serve his scenes with Jennifer Lopez are
also very strange there isn't much of a
plot here something about Baywatch and
how do you think Christopher Walken go
down to Marie Callender's get me a big
bowl tie some ice cream on it mmm good
put some on your head your tongue and
slap your brains out trying to get to it
interested go down the Marie Callender's
give me a big bowl pies but some ice
cream on it mmm mmm good
put some on your head your tongue would
slap your brains out trying to get you
it interested sure
[Music]
that didn't work
hello what what is this what is that
Pacino doing in this movie why does he
have a ponytail what and the number one
worst Ben Affleck performance is drool
atham in surviving Christmas it was
really close between this and Julie for
the top spot but I think in surviving
Christmas Affleck shares more of the
blame than in the total strange failure
that was Gigli rich young executive
drool atham has no close friends or
family and finds himself alone close to
Christmas in a cathartic act he visits
his child at home but finds a family
living there who he offers to pay two
hundred and fifty thousand dollars to
pretend to be his family for the
holidays they accept and drew gets on
their nerves very quickly things get
increasingly worse when the family's
daughter Alicia arrives this movie sucks
agreed that's like is supposed to be
obnoxious here but it's too much and he
never stops there's like one scene when
he's not trying to be annoying or
nervous and that seems okay what 99% of
the movie is this G first sorry Kevin
McCallister's mom also makes a return to
Christmas movies here because we all
wanted to see this dude it's your mom oh
my god hey can you print that for me
this kind of story has potential and I'm
sure it's been done better in another
movie but in this it's wasted the tone
of the comedy is confusing and it's one
of Affleck's lowest rated films I
survived surviving Christmas and so did
Ben that may have been the lowest point
in his career but since then the guy's
built back up a pretty good career for
himself I'm looking forward to see where
it goes from here I want to hear what
you guys think what is your least
favorite Ben Affleck movie and/or
performance what do you want me to cover
next on the show leave a comment and let
me know if you haven't already make sure
to go back and check out my top 5 best
Ben Affleck performances follow me on
twitter at awesome underscore walter and
make sure to come back next week when we
cruise and
a brand new top five
[Music]
[Applause]